je vais vous montrer on va rentrer dans
dans les ateliers en fait un bond en
remontant la chaîne de production à
l'envers collecter trier et rénover des
appareils électroménagers usagés voilà
la mission de l'association envie
attrape le but revendre les produits en
ligne ou en magasin 50% moins cher que
le prix du neuf dans le cadre du plan
relance les locaux trappistes ont
bénéficié d'une subvention de 12 mille
292 euros une somme qui vient s'ajouter
à d'autres aides de l'état un budget qui
servira à l'achat de véhicules
électriques et permettra
l'agrandissement et l'aménagement des
ateliers de réparation derrière moi on a
commencé à réinstaller un magasin de
pièces détachées d'occasion donc c'est
important pour nous dans nos process
d'utiliser un maximum de pièces issues
du réemploi et les subventions nous
permette de redresser complètement cet
espace de l'équipe et de la forme attisé
et d'avoir une gestion beaucoup plus
rationnelle et numérisés
de nos fables de pièces détachées ici
environ 4500 appareils sont rénovés
chaque année ils sont collectés auprès
de distributeurs ou chez des
particuliers
larry page a lieu en matinée les
produits sont triés ceux qui sont gardés
sont envoyés en atelier pour être réparé
tous les appareils que nous avons jugé
réparable aussi bien sur un point de vue
d'aspect
pas trop abîmer quoi après tout ce qui
touche à la mécanique ça c'est pas un
problème
donc ils sont mis dans la zone qui se
trouve derrière en attente de réparation
ensuite sa part dans les ateliers un
travail effectué principalement par des
salariés en insertion
une quarantaine d'opérateurs cherche et
répare les pannes des machines jetés
sont souvent recyclables le client
rejette parce qu'il ne connaît pas
le
la panne pour voir si ça marche pas il
jette pour nous c'est plus approfondie
dans ce camp ce qu'on recherche pour
ainsi réparer la machine dans les
yvelines une trentaine d'associations
comme envie à bénéficier du plan france
relance